he's arguably Twitter's most famous user
the US president Donald Trump has even
said Twitter one whom the White House
now he's at the center of a Twitter
storm after the social media company
flagged two of his tweets as misleading
for the first time Trump had tweeted to
his eighty million followers that mail
and ballots would lead to fraud Twitter
said his claims were false and had been
debunked by fact checkers there are two
areas where Twitter has said
specifically they would be more
aggressive one of those is
misinformation around the virus so we've
seen them take action against the
Brazilian president over that and then
also on election misinformation so this
is one of the two areas where they said
they'd be more aggressive that said they
have never taken action in three and a
half years of presidential tweets and
there have been plenty that have been
misleading Trump has hit back
accusing Twitter in a tweet of stifling
free speech and interfering in the
November election
but while Twitter's now taken its first
step against the president hours earlier
it refused to act over another series of
Trump's tweets where he suggested former
Republican congressman and US TV anchor
joe scarborough may have been involved
in the death of an intern 19 years ago
it's a very suspicious
thing and i hope somebody gets to the
bottom of it
trump's tweeted for years about the
unfounded allegations
even though lori claw Susie's death was
blamed on a heart issue last week her
widower wrote an open letter to Twitter
pleading with it to delete the posts
saying I'm asking you to intervene in
this instance because the President of
the United States has taken something
that does not belong to him the memory
of my dead wife and perverted it for
perceived political gain what the closu
disses the entire family have had to
endure for 19 years it's it's
unspeakably cruel for what whether it's
the president or whether it's people
following the president it is on
Vica bleah cruel social media companies
like Twitter Facebook and YouTube have
come under increasing pressure to act
faster and more effectively against
misinformation and hate speech on their
platforms twitter says the president's
posts about the TV host don't violate
its Terms of Service though it's working
to address issues like this going
forward thank you very much everybody
thank you Alexia O'Brien al-jazeera